cadjee ça te fait peur tout s'attaquer
lâche commis 24 ans s'est fait peur tout
sa fille pour tes parents pour bien sûr
j'ai très peur de le ramener chez moi
dans la famille donc c'est pour ça des
fois j'ai eu envie d'aller rejoindre des
amis pour qui faisait la fête tout et je
me suis toujours retenu de peur de
ramener cette toutes ces consignes toi
kenji oui je respecte au maximum parce
que j'ai trop peur si si si je ramène ça
chez moi ma mère et les fragiles
maintenant ils commencent à avoir
surnagé tout je m'en voudrais toute ma
vie même sur moi je veux pas attraper
cette ce virus là c'est du coup ça te
manque la scène parce que telle ou telle
porte parole du gouvernement estime
énormément ça mais j'aimerais demander
ces camps à peu près qu'on pourrait
aller en concert voir les va essayer de
donner du bonheur prévient il sur radio
c'est ouais non mais c'est du coup on a
eu carrément perdu nous aussi ça nous
manquait ça nous manque à tous et moi je
veux vraiment remercier les artistes qui
va continuer à garder un lien avec le
public aussi bas via les réseaux sociaux
internet et la démission parce que ça
remplace pas les concerts et ça remplace
pas la vie d'avant on a tous envie de
retrouver mais ça permet aussi de
permettre aux gens de s'évader quoi et
ça c'est hyper important
vous avez suivi la can si vous avez
suivi dans ce vol soit vous avez à coeur
je regarde une tarière est normal et
sain
c'est incroyable d'avoir du succès ce
qui fait vous êtes heureux donc porte
parole du gouvernement 31 ont passé une
super marque de confiance de m'avoir
confié ce job on n'a pas envie de
compter un an de s'amuser tout ça dès
samedi
d'abord
quand même pour moi et puis non enfin
c'est passionnant je pose la question
parce que je suis je suis dis
franchement c'est dur le plus facile ça
c'est sûr mais sans rigoler vous prenez
une critique vous avez à 31 ans faire
face tous les jours à des journalistes
ils sont pas forcément avec vous ça vous
plaît ça me plaît parce que moi j'ai
toujours aimé m'engager je vais
caricaturé mais j'étais délégué de
classe j'ai toujours aimé défendre des
intérêts des français et des autres
aussi jeter les gars tu as regardé comme
quoi ça mène à tous ma terrible savannah
trou et puis aussi parce que je pense on
a énormément de chance en france d'avoir
ce président de la république qui prend
ses décisions pour protéger les français
et donc je vais vous dire même si c'est
difficile même s'il ya des critiques
c'est quelque chose qui vous motive
parce que vous vous dites voilà on a de
la chance en france on n'est plus
protégé qu'ailleurs quand on repart avec
beaucoup de pays parce que mon a pris
des décisions qui sont difficile de dire
on met la santé avant toutes choses et
des gens qui en dit on va mettre
l'économie avant il se retrouve dans une
situation où c'est un carnage sur la
santé et en plus l'économie en souffrent
aussi puisque les gens forcément quand
il ya beaucoup de morts ils sortent pas
comme ils sortaient avant et c'est tout
ça c'est assez motivant alors j'espère
que on va pouvoir assez vite parler
d'autre chose que le coc vite parce que
n'est pas là uniquement pour gérer la
crise on est aussi là pour réformer le
pays
mais voilà pour répondre à la question
je suis heureux de faire ce que je fais
aujourd'hui que ça